[Aplausos]
[Música]
estonia
1991 tras más de 50 años de ocupación
soviética y dictadura comunista estonia
recuperaba su independencia el legado de
la época comunista para los estonios fue
al igual que para todos los países
restantes de la extinta unión soviética
de facto en 1991 el pib percápita
estonio no llegaba a los 3500 dólares el
equivalente hoy a países como bolivia o
'el salvador' claro que lo peor estaba
aún por llegar la desintegración del
bloque soviético supuso un duro mazazo
para sus países miembros por supuesto
estonia no fue una excepción en 1992 su
economía se contrajo más de un 20 por
ciento era a la hora de construir un
nuevo modelo de país y queridos amigos
amigas esta fue una idea que los
estonios se tomaron muy pero que muy en
serio mientras que algunos de los nuevos
países herederos de la unión soviética
como ucrania uzbekistán y bielorrusia se
hundieron en la inestabilidad
y la autocracia la historia de estonia
fue
completamente diferente
[Música]
el estonia es hoy uno de los países más
prósperos de todo el mundo su potencial
es inmenso y su nivel de vida no deja de
mejorar en 2020 el pib per cápita
ajustado por la diferencia de precios de
estonia se aproximó a los 40 mil dólares
algo que le ha permitido ya superar a
países como españa
[Música]
y eso no es todo la evolución de
prácticamente todos sus parámetros
macroeconómicos vence de largo no solo a
españa sino a la mayoría de países de la
unión europea por ejemplo es uno de los
países con las cuentas públicas más
saneadas de todo el mundo es el país de
europa con mayores tasas de
emprendimiento en relación a su
población cada año se crean más de 20
empresas por cada 1000 habitantes seis
veces más que la media comunitaria
queridos amigos amigas estonia se ha
convertido en el país de los
emprendedores europeos algo así como un
pequeño esos y gélido silicon valley en
plena unión europea pero dicho esto la
pregunta es cómo demonios han logrado
semejante evolución en tan poco tiempo
que esconde el modelo estonio cuáles son
los ingredientes de su éxito
[Música]
pues aquí tal y como ya os comentamos en
un vídeo especial en patrón podemos
destacar varios factores desde la
política fiscal hasta su apuesta por la
tecnología y también entre los
ingredientes más importantes del éxito
estonio se encuentra su sistema
educativo puede que no lo sepa así que
nunca te lo hubieras imaginado pero
estonia tiene el mejor sistema educativo
de toda europa de hecho se califica a sí
misma como la education nation la nación
de la educación pero queréis saber qué
tiene de especial su sistema educativo
cuáles son exactamente sus
características y claves más importantes
pues atentos
[Música]
más importante el como que el cuarto
el éxito del modelo educativo estonio no
es una opinión es algo acreditado por
todas las instituciones dedicadas a
evaluar los diferentes sistemas
educativos incluido por supuesto el
informe pisa en pisa estonia está
literalmente no solo a la cabeza de
europa sino de todo el mundo tras
singapur este pequeño país báltico es el
país que mejor calificación obtiene en
las tres competencias básicas lectura
matemáticas y ciencias
y no sólo eso esto también tiene el
mayor porcentaje del mundo de
estudiantes con alto rendimiento
académico que provienen de familias
pobres y la menor diferencia en
resultados entre el entorno rural y el
entorno urbano la menor tasa de
estudiantes sin educación básica apenas
un 5% y una de las tasas de repetición
de cursos más bajas de toda la ocde y es
que apenas el 3,5 de los estudiantes de
hasta 15 años repiten alguna vez frente
a la media del 12 4% por si fuera poco
también se coloca la cabeza en cuanto a
dominio de lenguas extranjeras
[Música]
amigos aquí el ascensor social funciona
a toda velocidad y para que nos
entendamos podemos decir que estonia ha
adelantado por la derecha al sistema
educativo de la mismísima finlandia el
hasta ahora referente de toda europa en
materia educativa ahora bien como lo han
conseguido justo aquí se lo que muchos
estáis pensando alberto seguro seguro
que se gastan una barbaridad en
educación pues no estáis muy pero que
muy equivocados
[Música]
estonia hace un importante esfuerzo en
educación pero el gasto público por
alumno no es ni de lejos el más alto de
la ocde ni siquiera si ajustamos el
gasto por la diferencia de precios y
salarios de hecho hay muchos países con
un gasto por alumno muy superior y que
sin embargo obtienen resultados mucho
peores creéis un ejemplo pues sin ir más
lejos españa fijaos
y ya lo veis a pesar de cosechar
holgadamente los mejores resultados
educativos estonia no es ni de lejos el
país que más gasta en educación por
alumno de hecho su nivel de gasto se
sitúa bastante por debajo de la media de
la ocde y de la unión europea incluso si
tenemos en cuenta la diferencia de
precios lo cual nos lleva directamente a
una idea que creo que conviene repetir
no señores políticos no gastar más en
educación no es la receta simple del
éxito si fuera tan sencillo sería muy
fácil nos parece bastaría con gastar más
y más para obtener mejores resultados
pero la realidad sin embargo es
totalmente diferente esto no va de
cuánto se gasta sino sobre todo de cómo
así que por favor políticos y
periodistas de todos los colores y
partidos dejar graves por todas de
utilizar el mantra del dinero
pongamos otro ejemplo islandia gasta por
alumno mucho muchísimo más que estonia e
incluso repito teniendo en cuenta la
diferencia de salarios y precios así que
si nos guiamos por la lógica política de
que a más gasto mejores resultados
entonces islandia tendría que tener un
sistema educativo mucho mejor que
estonia sin embargo o sorpresa sorpresa
no es que estonia gane es que islandia
por ejemplo en pizza es uno de los
peores países de europa el gasto amigos
no lo es todo pero he hecho esto y ahora
que ya sabemos que no es simplemente una
cuestión de pasta que os parece si nos
ponemos el buzo de trabajo y nos
sumergimos de lleno en las claves del
sistema educativo de estonia que podemos
aprender de él atentos
[Música]
los pilares de la prosperidad historia
querida comunidad de visual política
resetea nuestra mente durante un buen
rato porque el modelo educativo del que
os vamos a hablar seguro seguro que
tiene poco que ver con lo que hayáis
visto hasta ahora vamos a hablar de un
modelo educativo que extrañamente no
está subordinado a intereses políticos
sino a las necesidades de capital humano
que tiene el mundo moderno incluyendo
por supuesto el mundo de la empresa y el
emprendimiento espera espera un momento
un sistema educativo diseñado para que
los estudiantes puedan encontrar un
trabajo de alta cualificación
rápidamente al terminar sus estudios de
locos pues si no nos hemos equivocado en
estonia la educación se ha situado como
uno de los ejes clave sobre los que
pivotan los planes económicos del país
ahora bien en que esa diferencia
exactamente el modelo educativo estonio
del de otros países pues veréis la
primera clave la podemos encontrar en la
independencia independencia tanto de
escuelas como de profesores
[Música]
aunque en estonia todos los centros
educativos tienen que ceñirse a un
programa marco de contenidos mínimos
fijados por el gobierno la aplicación de
este marco es muy abierta en cada
colegio instituto o incluso cada
profesor tiene mucha independencia para
decidir tanto el currículo educativo
final como el método
[Música]
y creedme si os digo que tanto centros
como profesores son los primeros
interesados en que todo esto funcione
entre otras cosas por el modelo estonio
dual de financiación pública de la
educación espera espera modelo que
querían tres es eso pues veréis en
estonia la educación privada es
testimonial residual anecdótica sin
embargo lo cierto es que los centros
educativos públicos están sometidos a un
intenso modelo de competencia
[Música]
por un lado la financiación de los
centros sigue una filosofía que se
parece bastante al proceso de
competencia de mercado y es que el
ingreso que las escuelas reciben está
determinado por el número de alumnos que
consigan cuantos más alumnos logró un
centro un mayor será su financiación por
otro lado el rendimiento académico las
características de cada centro se
evalúan constantemente y los resultados
son totalmente públicos esto genera la
dinámica competitiva de que los padres
quieran inscribir a sus hijos en los
mejores colegios e institutos los cuales
a lograr más alumnos consiguen más
financiación en este proceso además
incrementa la presión sobre los
responsables y profesores de los centros
con peor rendimiento haciendo que se
tengan que poner las pilas
[Música]
y no sólo eso ya no se trata solo de que
los mejores colegios e institutos logren
más demanda más reputación y más
recursos sino que además los buenos
resultados garantizan también su
supervivencia porque amigos uno de los
grandes retos a los que se enfrenta a
estonia es la demografía en los últimos
15 años el número de estudiantes en el
país ha caído un 40% lo que ha obligado
al gobierno y a los municipios a ir
cerrando los colegios e institutos que
sobraban eso si se cierran los que
peores resultados obtienen así que ya os
podéis imaginar el interés que tanto las
escuelas como los profesores tienen para
mejorar sus resultados y atraer más
alumnos por cierto que en este punto hay
que decir que los directores y los
órganos de dirección de cada centro
cuentan con un nivel de autonomía muy
alto para cosas como por ejemplo decidir
a qué profesores contratan qué salario
reciben o cómo reparten los fondos que
reciben del gobierno
si lo habéis escuchado bien los salarios
de los profesores en estonia no son los
mismos en todas las escuelas y se
determina mediante convenio colectivo se
deciden en los propios centros por
supuesto cuantos más fondos reciba un
centro mayores salarios podrá pagar es
simple y llanamente el resultado de la
competencia además esta enorme autonomía
permite que cada centro pueda
diferenciarse de otros y
especializándose en diferentes
cuestiones arte economía ciencias
etcétera etcétera incluso existen las
llamadas escuelas de élite un tipo de
centro pensado para poder desarrollar
todas las capacidades de los alumnos más
brillantes pero aquí no termina todo los
profesores también están supeditados a
mayores niveles de competencia y más
responsabilidades que en otros países
en estonia si los alumnos tienen malos
resultados de forma prolongada el
profesor puede ser despedido pero para
no tener que llegar a este extremo en
este país los profesores reciben una
intensa formación continua lo que les
permite mejorar y reciclarse en cuanto a
conocimientos contenidos o métodos de
enseñanza es una formación intensa y
obligatoria que conlleva muchos
beneficios por ejemplo la adaptación a
las nuevas tecnologías
a cambio los profesores cuentan con más
libertad docente e influencia en la toma
de decisiones no os parece sorprendente
todo absolutamente todo el modelo
educativo de estonia se basa en la
competencia y recordad que hablamos de
un sistema esencialmente público parece
casi de otro mundo ahora bien llegas a
este punto es posible que os estáis
preguntando vale vale pero como es
exactamente el currículum escolar tiene
algo que ver con la altísima tasa de
creación de empresas que tiene el país
bien atentos
cuando con todo hasta el éxito final
lo mencionamos ya al principio del vídeo
el modelo educativo de estonia está
orientado sobre todo a la empresa y a la
preparación para el mundo laboral por
ejemplo en el diseño de los programas
académicos participan tanto
representantes de la sociedad civil como
de las propias empresas pero esa no es
la única vía de colaboración tanto la
educación secundaria como la educación
terciaria cuentan con amplios programas
de prácticas laborales que permiten que
los estudiantes estonios accedan al
mercado laboral con algo de experiencia
en este sentido estonia ha apostado muy
fuerte por incluir las prácticas de
trabajo en la educación vocacional que
sería el equivalente a la fp aquí a la
formación profesional y también en los
másteres universitarios y ojo que no
hablamos del típico mes de prácticas
estos programas contemplan que las
prácticas laborales supongan hasta el 50
por ciento de las horas de formación
pero al margen de la colaboración con
empresas podemos destacar otra
característica muy particular los
estonios están obsesionados con la
igualdad en la etapa educativa y no
hablamos de una igualdad entendida como
hacer que todos consigan el título sino
que todos tengan las mismas condiciones
sea cual sea su entorno y socioeconómico
es decir igualdad de oportunidades no de
resultados
esto supone que en estonia no solo la
educación está pagada por el estado
incluida la universidad sino también los
libros de texto e incluso el comedor los
estudiantes de educación obligatoria
tienen comida gratis en la escuela
además todos los alumnos hasta los 19
años tienen una cobertura sanitaria
gratuita así como enfermeras en los
colegios de primaria chequeos médicos
rutinarios gratuitos y dentista gratis
[Música]
la idea fundamental es que sea cual sea
su nivel socioeconómico todos los
estudiantes puedan tener las mismas
oportunidades
en fin competencia especialización e
integración con la empresa e igualdad de
oportunidades en un país con poca
burocracia y bajos impuestos no está
nada mal nos parece por supuesto no todo
es perfecto aunque el sistema educativo
de estonia ha demostrado ser hoy por hoy
el mejor de toda europa con mucha
diferencia todavía tiene algún que otro
reto sobre todo dos la escasez de
profesores de materias específicas y la
mejora en el rendimiento educativo de
los estudiantes de etnia rusa
[Música]
queridos amigos amigas estas son las
claves del modelo educativo de estonia
el mejor sistema educativo de toda
europa y uno de los mejores del mundo
uno de los ingredientes que ha permitido
que este país no solo de un enorme salto
en prosperidad sino que se convierta
también en un líder tecnológico en todo
un semillero de startups la pregunta es
creéis que vuestro país debería tomar
nota del éxito estonio que os gustaría
ver en vuestros países dejadnos muchos
comentarios aquí abajo y como siempre si
te ha gustado este vídeo dale al botón
de like y suscríbete a nuestro canal
haciendo clic en la campanita y por
cierto si te gusta el trabajo que
hacemos apóyanos y únete a nuestra
comunidad en patrio donde además de
contribuir con visual política obtendrás
contenidos exclusivos así como regalos
periódicos y mucho más os dejamos el
enlace abajo en la descripción un saludo
y hasta la próxima
[Música]